[Musik]
in dem Kreis
[Musik],
der identifiziert, dass wir Tiere sind
und natürlich, wenn das wahr ist, dann gibt
es für mich nicht mehr als den Rest des Tieres
, das wir bereits hier stehen, oh, ich weiß
weniger, dasselbe weiß ich nicht  alle Rätsel lösen,
was wir sind, weil Sie
uns kürzlich einer allgemeinen
Kategorie zugeteilt haben, über die Sie auch Probleme ansprechen
können, also wer nicht,
es muss dasselbe sein. Ich denke, es ist
vernünftig, dass wir sind und das ist die
Folge davon  Begriff Person,
der in philosophischer
Hinsicht mit dem Problem in Verbindung gebracht wird. Das
Problem ist, was für Dinge wir sind.
Der Begriff Person wird so groß von seiner
Mitte
Zeit und kann alle C's mit einbeziehen, das ist
, dass die Logik von The Tempest
ist, dass wir das sagen sollten, denn wenn wir sagen, wenn
wir sagen, dass wenn dann kein Grund klar wird,
warum die folgenden all dies
mal anders überlegen und sich überlegen  Orte,
was das bedeutet und warum Lock
diese Definition aufstellt, bucht er nur,
dass Menschen viele dieser drei Funktionen haben.
Ich meine, eines der offensichtlichsten Merkmale
des Menschen im menschlichen Leben wäre
emotional. Wir sind
hochemotionale Wesen  so etwas wie
die wirklich wichtigen Eigenschaften des Menschen
, um die paar Qualitäten zu erwähnen, natürlich
[Musik]
sowieso, das ist lustig, das möchte
ich sagen, ich spreche da nur etwas unhöflich
, okay,
also jetzt alle paar über unsere Natur, aber
ich kenne mich aus  Die Gesichter fallen
oder das ist eine Menge Bemerkung, die jeder
gemacht hat, was so etwas wie
das Fotografieren ist, das Sie in diesem Bereich anprobieren.
Irgendwann ist es sehr schwierig,
eine Ansicht zu bekommen, die nicht zufriedenstellend ist,
wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, auch es
scheint  mir scheint, und was mir scheint, ist das
Hauptproblem oder die Art der Kommentare, mit denen
der Animalismus konfrontiert ist
Ursprünglich wurden
Gehirntransplantationen als Schuhmacher weltweit bekannt,
aber es war
[Musik]
zwei Dinge eine
andere Sache, es war in diesem Stadium nicht
auf Tiere und Beuteltiere ausgerichtet, wir
dachten es nicht, aber mit dem Aufkommen
des animismus das gehirn
[musik]
du weißt, warum das gehirn beteiligt war
gut okay ist, dass du nicht mit der
pause gehst du bricht eigentlich nicht okay du
weißt was du musst du musst dich
den intuitionen widersetzen die du mit der
welt gehst  die Schwierigkeiten bereiten.
Als ich auf diesen Artikel stieß, werde ich mich
daran erinnern, dass er mich interessierte. Ja, ich denke
sicher, ich weiß, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, dem
ich zustimme, aber es scheint mir,
dass wir Annapolis im Grunde vermissen könnten
Frauen sind Tiere,
aber er möchte die Art der Gehirntransplantation vermeiden,
indem er argumentiert,
dass Sie nach einer korrekten Analyse dessen,
was ein Tier oder ein menschliches Tier ist,
sagen sollten, dass ein menschliches Tier mit
dem Gehirn in Ordnung ist, und wenn Sie diese Behauptung
stimmen  Wenn diese Behauptung richtig ist,
dann war es eine Illusion zu glauben, dass
die Intuitionen über
Gehirntransplantationen Schwierigkeiten für das Tier waren, ist in
Ordnung, also im Grunde gibt Ihnen die Idee
[Musik]
der Fall selbst keine
sofortige Entscheidung, ganz recht
darüber nachzudenken
[Musik]
Okay Okay jetzt habe ich Angst davor, was gleichbedeutend mit
Matratzenknallen ist Fortsetzung
Okay, dann können Sie auf Seite zwei
die Zusammenfassung der Atmosphäre erhalten,
also sprechen Sie über eine
makroskopische Fortsetzung, jetzt ist die Idee  ein
makroskopisches kontinuum könnte ein tisch sein ein
computer hunde katzen bäume
die idee ist im grunde, wenn wir an
die welt denken an die objekte
darin denken gibt es objekte, die
wahrnehmbar sein werden begegnen wir
in unserer umgebung unserem wahrnehmungssystem nicht widersprechen müssen
Okay, was denken Sie, wenn
Sie sich mit diesen Objekten beschäftigen, ist ein
Projekt. Die Aktivitäten dieser Bilder.
Dies ist eine Gruppe. Sie erkennen, dass
[Musik],
aber wir untersuchen auch, ein
Kontinuumsobjekt ist  Was nicht
durch ein makroskopisches Objekt erfüllt werden muss,
um bestehen zu bleiben
, das ist wieder eine theoretische Sache, auf die Sie hingewiesen haben
, was das Tier ist, sagt, dass wir
Tiere sind und dass einer von uns verurteilt ist,
die charakteristische Aktivität
ständig zu bewahren  die Aufzeichnungen
okay kontinuierlich denken bewusst
Schmerz Emulation Depression Hochgefühl usw.
usw. Ich sagte, die Bandbreite der Dinge, die Sie
bewahren, ist die Sache
[Musik]
[Applaus],
weil Sie ohne ohne überleben können,
wenn Sie
irgendwo wieder brillant sind  zu deinem Gehirn, also
hier ist mehr
[Musik],
weil diese Intuitionen, dass du
mit dem Gehirn gehst, was animalische
[Musik]
einfacher ist, nun,
vielleicht richtig,
ich meine, ich finde mich interessant
[Musik]
ist
wegen der Nahrung in deinem Mund, aber
die Verdauung der
[Musik]
Ich meine Charaktere [ __ ]
grasen langsam
das Gras herunter, aber einfach pflegen  nach
unten geht es auch darum, sich zu streiten, dass
er nur deine Position zu einem
Zeitpunkt ändert, der normalerweise nicht als eine
Art kausaler Prozess angesehen wird, es ist ein räumlicher,
es ist ein schwacher
Gegensatz, also bringt die nächste Aktivität keine Entscheidungsfreiheit,
so eine Sache  Wir haben
[Musik]
-Aktivitäten gesehen, die er vielleicht erwarten könnte, mit
diesem Gedanken an einen Ball, der zum Ende des
Bretagne-Fensters fliegt, der Ball durch Glas platzt,
das Fenster zerschmettert, das
würden wir sagen, und das ist etwas, was der
Ball tut, aber Martine sagte  was
macht das fenster was macht das fenster
gut natürlich was wir sagen ist das das
fenster zerschmettert es fällt einfach auseinander aber
das sieht so aus als wäre es nur ein effekt der
effekt ist das das fenster zerschmettert aber
Martine wies darauf hin das das fenster
den ball verlangsamt der ball  kommt heraus,
trifft das Fenster, es behält nicht die
Geschwindigkeit bei,
das Fenster lädt jetzt richtig, und
zweitens ändert sich die Ballform
so geringfügig, wenn es den Gewinner richtig trifft,
also ist es nicht so, wie
wir es uns vorstellen  s über dem Fenster ist ein
passives Subjekt, die Bälle sind großartig,
richtig, aber das stimmt überhaupt
nicht, was es tut, ist nicht,
dass der Ball etwas im
normalen Sinne einer Aktivität tut, der Ball ist
nur  Wenn Sie langsamer werden und Ihren Schuppen wechseln
, reagiert er auf die Täuschung, also
möchte ich sagen, dass die Wende ein sehr geeigneter Zeitpunkt ist, da
das Fenster so
beschaffen ist, dass ich Noreen und Amandas Bar bin. Es
stellt eindeutig eine lange Verbindungsbeziehung zwischen
mir und mir dar  Das Weltmerkmal der
grundlegenden Objekte in Bezug auf
Fähigkeiten und Macht sind die Aktivitäten
in der Natur, aber was
für diese Art von Entitäten ebenso charakteristisch
ist, ist, wie sie auf Dinge reagieren und
wie ich denke, dass sie in bestimmten Situationen funktionieren
, die keines von beiden sind, nachdem Materie ignoriert wurde
und all diese Merkmale sind sichtbares
Licht in ihrer Beziehung, im
Grunde
[Musik]
es ist nicht gut
Material nicht also was bedeutet es, was,
wenn es das bedeutet  Wir melden die
Änderungen, die wir
einem für das Thema bestimmten Prädikat anhängen, also sagen wir
Dinge wie Schlüssel Essen verdauen Ich
verdaue Essen, wenn wir auch
letzten Donnerstag visualisiert haben, damit Sie
sprachlich gesprochen eine
Redeweise haben, die die Aktivität zuordnet  Richtig
, das ist eine sprachliche Denkweise von
makroskopisch, aber soweit ich
diese beiden Begriffe sehen kann,
finde ich es sehr seltsam
, dass wir einen mikroskopischen Prozess zirkulieren, es ist
materiell mikroskopisch, aber sagen wir,
ich zirkuliere wie Blut, berichten wir
dass es ein ziemlich guter Gebrauch ist,
nein, wir sind gekommen, um Dinge zu sagen, wie Sie wissen, dass
das Herz etwas
dafür verantwortlich ist - wir sagen,
was ich tue.
Ja, ich zirkuliere diese Uhr
Material
spricht groß, aber die Glyzinie wird nicht
auf diese Art und Weise gemeldet. Nein, was
denkst du, was den Führern übrig lässt,
ist, dass dieser Zustand
nicht sehr ave aussieht  Sehr sensibel,
weil es nicht richtig sein kann zu verlangen,
dass die einzigen Aktivitäten von praktisch oder
was hast du makroskopisch aussetzen oder
leider gerade jetzt tun, und wenn du sagst,
was wirklich zählt, ist, wie wirst du es
melden, meldest du, wenn ich das sage
Agent hat das Thema genommen oder ich tue
es oder nicht, das heißt,
in unserer Reihe von Systemen
eine gewisse Bedeutung beizumessen, um einer Art zu sprechen,
die nichts tiefes widerspiegelt
Dinge von
deren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sind, wenn Sie denken, dass sie eine große
Anzahl von Dingen enthalten werden,
die für Menschen nicht charakteristisch sind, als eine Art Okay,
also wäre nur eine Art eher ähnlicher
Veranlagung, dass ich
mit der Veranlagung geboren wurde, etwas Bestimmtes zu haben  Farbe
jetzt, wenn wir darüber nachdenken, was es tut
[Musik]
So wie es mich braucht, gibt es da einen Zug
, dessen Logik ich nicht ganz
verstehe, wie warum sollte der nur
die Eigenschaften brauchen, die von allen geteilt werden
mit allen  Menschen in meiner Zeit
richtig und es könnte in der Formel stehen,
was die
charakteristischen Aktivitäten sein werden, die ich bin,
wegen Worten, meiner Beharrlichkeit, an denen ich jetzt interessiert bin
konstitutiv für die Systeme müssen
Merkmale sein, die alle menschlichen Tiere haben,
okay, weil sie überlebt haben,
müssen sie alle die gleiche Bedingung erfüllen
, also müssen die fraglichen Merkmale
alle von Menschen geteilt werden, das
stimmt, aber es sagt das nicht  der
Sinn, in dem alles, was
Beharrlichkeit ausmacht, geteilt werden muss, aber
daraus folgt nicht, dass die
Merkmale in Beziehung stehen müssen
, um Kapazitäten über Schwierigkeitsgewinne hinweg zu teilen
, die nicht den Zustand bilden, der
von einem zum anderen geht, sondern
zweitens auch Erika Erika An dieser
Stelle ist es durchaus möglich zu denken,
dass die Beharrlichkeitsmilizen, die
ziemlich wenige Wesen sind, sich auf andere Arten von
Angelegenheiten beziehen, richtig
acht und so weiter und so weiter  In gewisser
Weise gibt es also keine Rechtfertigung dafür
, typische Menschen
in Ihre Krankenschwesternpositionen zu bringen, bei
denen wir alle in Ordnung sind. Lassen Sie mich
nur vier andere Schwierigkeiten durchgehen.
Jetzt geht es
um das, was er hält  die
Persistenz eines Artefakts, aber wenn wir
an ein solches Artefakt denken, scheint
ein Toaster eine Formel zu sein, die für Toaster gilt,
weil es bedeutet, mittelgroße Fortsetzungen anzuwenden,
aber es ist nicht klar, dass er
für eine Sache tut, die
Toaster als Gruppe nicht teilen  Eine große
Anzahl von Gesetzen wie Kalkül ergibt sich,
weil Toaster aus allen
möglichen Dingen richtig gemacht werden können und sie
auf alle möglichen Arten gestaltet werden
können  Wenn Sie an Toaster denken, werden Sie diese gemeinsamen
charakteristischen Aktivitäten einer langen Zeit nicht
über die
Kursteilnehmer hinwegbekommen  Jeder, der den
Begriff eines Toasters beherrscht, weiß, was Toaster
sind, denn es ist niemand, der einfach
einen Toaster aussuchen kann. Sie müssen erkennen,
dass ein Toaster tatsächlich der Name ist
, der ziemlich klar macht, dass wir uns dabei helfen
, das auf Englisch zu tun by  Verwenden Sie das gleiche Wort,
aber das Objekt, dessen Rolle es
nach der Aktivität fragt, also Toaster, Backofen, Toaster,
andererseits scheint diese Funktion
für uns nicht erhalten zu
sein
etwas, das
kein Brot mehr toasten kann,
aber was ist das, warum sagst du nicht einfach
, ich habe einen kaputten Toaster, es könnte
nicht in Ordnung sein, nichts Geheimnisvolles daran,
es ist eindeutig,
es ist immer noch da, kann nichts tun,
okay, es ist offiziell
Nun, das Reisen ist als Slogan oder
[Musik] von
Natur aus unklar, ob ich damit überlebe,
aber das ist bewiesen, weil wir wissen, dass es eine
Entscheidung ist, Hilfe anzubieten, aber wenn
Sie sagen, ich lese das nicht noch einmal,
was ist die Vision, was ist eigentlich die
Vision, wie geht es uns
sozusagen [Musik] okay, jetzt, wo die Herangehensweise des Menschen
Beharrlichkeit mit Bewahrung verbindet, das ist das
Beste im Jiu-Jitsu, eine Sache, die so
lange bestehen bleibt, wie ihre legale Existenz
etwas bewahrt, das sie auswählt, wenn sie
versucht, es sogar zu taufen  Recht,
Persistenzerhaltung
jetzt zu verlinken Ich repariere es nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass,
solange Sie über das System nachdenken,
weil es viele Beispiele gibt,
wo Persistenz nicht dasselbe ist wie
Erhaltung, was für ein Fall
wäre  radikale Verwandlung Diener im Leben,
also das zweite Beispiel bist du, wenn das
Licht der Schmetterlinge Momente hat, in
denen sich eine bestimmte Phase im Leben des Tieres
ziemlich radikal ändert und es
eine andere Phase seines Lebens gibt, sie
ändern sich, okay, jetzt können wir die Linie glücklich verfolgen
, aber wir  Ich habe nicht darüber nachgedacht, wie
wichtig es ist, dass, wenn es
transformiert wird, Kriege bestehen bleiben
und nicht das erste mit
der Transformation ist, dass die Transformation
in die neue Phase übergeht  Alle
möglichen Unterschiede zum anderen Aspekt,
also sollte diese Art von Fall
Ihr Gefühl schwächen, dass die Analyse der
Beharrlichkeit mit Erhaltung zu tun haben sollte.
Ich meine, was wirklich
Kerl, aber in gewissem Sinne ist es,
wenn Sie sehen, wie sich ein Kind entwickelt
denken, es ist derselbe job, dein fokus
liegt nicht auf einem gefangenen, was schon gott
oh gott und es ist uns egal, das ist nicht das, worauf
du dich konzentrierst, worauf du dich auf die
ehren konzentrierst, was ist es eine ruhige
ich denke, nichts entwickelt sich, wie sich die dinge
ändern  - In
solchen Fällen gibt es etwas, das die Veränderung
hervorruft. Beharrlichkeit
Ich bin keine Ablenkung, und wir zeigen Ihnen,
dass Beharrlichkeit in
Bezug auf die Erhaltung einer traumatischen Verletzung
kein Haustier ist. Wir hatten keine wirklichen Schwierigkeiten
herauszufinden, wer glücklich ist
aber sie sind nicht die Art von Bild
[Musik]
sowieso okay